margot robbie looking sexy in a new and
provocative spot for Calvin Klein and
only we are behind the scenes of the
shoot but here's the thing about Margo
she is a bona fide superstar a
world-class beauty and even in the
middle of a very Hollywood moment she is
still grounded here's the proof check
her out getting cozy on a bed with
several shirtless models and dancing her
way through a hallway party but there's
more to Margo than meets the eye
when I was growing up I'd wanted to own
hotels and I wanted to be a magician I
didn't go down those paths necessarily
but I think I did gravitate towards like
sort of entertaining and the business
side of things a hotel owning magician
Margot's unique childhood dream is just
one of the many reasons we're diggin on
the 26 year old aussi despite being the
face of Calvin Klein's deep eforea
fragrance she's all about
low-maintenance makeup I think every
time I put on a foundation I was
difficuit tip into eye makeup remover
and I just like to remove the foundation
for my lips and then I don't eat away
like lipstick because it's just I don't
know that seems to work for me a
reluctant fitness routine I don't really
have one I don't really have the
discipline to go to the gym all the time
or eat really healthy all the time if I
can trick myself into thinking it's a
fun activity and not exercise than I
like doing it and as for her biggest
crush the most beautiful person I know
is my mom I know everyone says that but
if he met my mom you would be like oh
she is the most like wonderful woman in
the world I feel most flattered when
people say how much I look like my mom
because I just hope that one day I look
as good as she does in her sixties
you